Tony in the movie my big break we see
that you were roommates with four then
undiscovered actors this was back in the
90s yes
97 ok how did you all come together how
did you meet we I met Greg on a movie
and then Greg introduced and I met Greg
and Brad and then through Greg we met
Chad and then we all moved in Greg was
there first
Chad was there second and then Brad and
I moved at the same time and then later
on Wes Morgan okay and at the time you
didn't really realize that you were
doing a documentary you were sort of was
it well yeah we were just yeah we were
just roommates and we we you know I
think we lived there for like a year and
then that's when I realized that we
would shoot occasionally but not with
the intention of like doing a
documentary by everybody was trying to
express themselves with cameras and
acting and and then a year later I think
that's when the whole concept developed
and it's like okay this is interesting
that stuff filming okay and how did they
feel about you filming them were they
excited about it at first oh yeah I'm
the beginning very supportive because
you know it was something to do and the
possibilities I mean we didn't know what
could happen also we didn't nobody had
agents and managers and people telling
you
what to do what not to do I mean it was
it was almost like work that could bring
in possibilities down the line so
everybody was like okay this is
greatness trying yeah
so then how far into you're moving into
Maslin did stuff start to take off for
these other actors between pretty quick
pretty quick I mean Chad was getting
some parts but very like small roles and
then Brad started to get a lot of work
especially after he went to Sundance and
then a year later probably or two years
then West moved in and he is also
starting to work really fast so so it
was kind of one guy would take off and
another guy would move in and it would
make it and then a third so we were just
kind of I was surprising so what was the
energy in the house like at that time
because I'm sure it was it feast or
famine what was it everything sort of at
snow balled all at once or steadily
steadily it climbed up it was really
more it's always done expected like
everybody was open for what could happen
next and so it there was a period where
when they started to work it was always
every few days somebody would open the
door and say I got another part so just
like it would almost kind of got older
that everybody was working at one point
you know I mean you look back at it now
and I go wow but when it was happening
was like oh that's great I mean
and how many hours of footage did you
capture probably over 200 - yeah and
then did you start making the
documentary while you were still living
at Maslin or did you move and then make
it in terms of like editing the movie
together no I started editing when I was
at Maslin like about maybe five years
later five four four and I started to
assemble everything but back then
editing systems were very expensive so
there was a time when I rented the
system and then now became very costly
then I found a studio where I could go
at it there and then so I would edit and
then I would stop and then I would film
longer and I would just stay in way and
then I would find another solution or
just get more money and I would edit
again so we just there was a on and off
and then at what point did you actually
screen the movie when it was it it was
finished and then you finally had a
screening in what happened when it got
accepted at Toronto that was the first
time I didn't even show the guys what I
did they did see I think a couple of
them saw a cut of the film William
Morris in their theatre downstairs and
that was once the movie was accepted
that's when they were representing the
film and and the other two I think saw
it at the festival for the first time
they didn't really know me nobody saw
the whole movie completed until the
festival zone and you were still living
in the house yeah okay yeah we're all
still there but at the time the movie
was done when we went to Toronto Brad
was our he was married and and Chet had
moved out so we're just like Wes myself
and Greg were still at ours
so tell us about September 10th -
we screamed the evening not knowing what
would happen the next day on the 11th we
we had a great great screening I think
was like almost about a thousand people
came to it was a big theater you know we
were flying high I mean that was great
like after all that work well we have we
could actually have a movie to show you
know we celebrated everything was great
and then we were amorous at the time
they were talking about like the game
they were gonna make a deal with someone
who should be the one to go with which
company that should pick up the film
there were all a lot of options so I
figure you know I'll just do it the next
day let's you know everybody chill out
and just do their thing and enjoy the
moment and then we woke up in the
morning and with that tax happened so
once that happened this festival
suspended the whole programming they
just closed and they decided they're
just not gonna continue the festival
they did continue I think about for
three days later they felt like well
care what everybody's stuck there might
as well just continue showing the films
which was a bad idea anyway it was over
you know and a lot of people nobody was
really thinking about movies at that you
know once that happened it was like
everybody was trying to figure out how
we're gonna get back you know so people
stopped
talking about movies or buying movies or
showing movies even when they did
everybody was very tense so we did have
another screening but it was it was a
big screening and I think people were
looking for a way to escape and just to
kill time but it was very good but the
project I mean you know it was just
didn't have that same feeling it's the
first night and so was there talk that
maybe some of the agents of these
roommates were uncomfortable with
showing no no not not a not in Toronto I
think it's when it was screened here
because the main agents that way amorous
switcher from West and stuff like that I
think they were very tense but they saw
the movie here when we screened it you
know one of the theaters in LA I think
that's word that you know about you know
looking back now I don't think because
it was the movie I think also because I
think because there was a you know West
was going through a weird period the
movie was kind of almost in their eyes
validating his behavior in the sense
they felt like if it came out well all
do we really need this right now so I
think that's where the tension was
coming from
and then take us to some of the low
points then because eventually you
destroy the film and you leave Hollywood
what timespan are we looking at from the
screening to the point that you leave
and and where were you in your life well
I think it really happened because once
we came back and they couldn't sell the
film and people started disappearing I
mean nobody disappeared as disappeared
but they wanted to take the movie for
nothing like first we were gonna buy it
now we could take it off your hand
because you had you know this horrible
event happened and it like killed the
heat on the film so but we're willing to
take off your head even somebody
actually asked if I would pay them to
take the movie you know where'd you get
that stuff from I have no idea and
somebody said Hollywood something I
don't want to mention names that they
actually would release your film if you
would pay him for promoting it so you
need to go actually find money to
release your own film and so I was like
we went from we're gonna sell the movie
to like I'll take it off your hand to
like actually we were charged it at
least you remove me so I'm like alright
it's a very interesting town and I think
that's what I hit bottom I just couldn't
believe it I was just like I'm you're
joking I mean this is like absurd
because this is a festival so it's like
he it's not like the whole world know
that the movie was coming on and
something happened and they don't want
to see it anymore but I guess that heat
that they're talking about more about
the buyers you know it's like they all
want something is when they all like
fighting over something and when
nobody's interested and then you have a
problem so I just didn't accept that and
I became very upset about that and so I
decided you know write it and like see
what happens I waited but then waiting
you know in LA is very difficult and
then it became very frustrated you know
and then at the time too my friends were
like Stan it also hit rock bottom in a
way of like they were you know there was
like a lot of confusion there was a lot
of depression you know the typical thing
that you made it but then now you start
sabotage so just like the whole scene
was messy you know it was very nervous
down
you